this is not going to go particularly
well I have a feeling but let us begin
here on C and then quickly move to D
[Music]
hello my name staff good amide Emily
that Hillary Clinton alien but just
because he thinks is aliens and um it's
done he's not a good brother just a
funny told me he was building aa blue
dad - dad you know I'm proud of you
[Music]
well you thought I was in a blue but I
was hiding in a box
people love is the cygwin data talks oh
yeah who named it Falcon yeah he needs a
shrink
no one of the bad can make everyone
think they're in a balloon
now I'm famous too I was nothing in a
box when it cut the Palouse in
immediately cut the color my local news
and everyone who watch TV thumb and ham
I died but the Attic was closed as it
got to this guide and the next day I was
on the national news
they asked me why I hid until I PU
so I was a little balloon but I wasn't
in a balloon they called me the balloon
boy but I wasn't in a blue
oh yeah I like that day me Falcon him
yeah he needs a shrink but no one else's
that can make everyone think they're in
the blue
and I'm famous too and now everyone
wants to take my dad away from me
because they contribute to the matter
they could see but Danny please tell me
what I really but I know do you think
we'll never get another TV show cuz the
kids at school keep telling me this tale
about how wife swap has a different
meaning in Jane
well I thought I was in a balloon but I
was hiding in a box
people always told me to listen when
data talks so yeah and even about and
yeah he needs a shrink but no one up
says that can't make everyone think
they're in the blue
[Music]
so I'm gonna give you all break and
that's all I'm gonna do I'm not gonna
tell you all the insightful things that
I think Balloon Boy tells us about
America today I'm gonna do that tomorrow
actually tomorrow I think I'm gonna talk
about hoaxes and how they're nothing new
and there's probably no reason we should
be surprised that this happened because
it's happened hundreds of times since
the beginning of news media began the
beginning began when did the beginning
begin the beginning of the beginning was
a long time ago anyway Oh PS you may
have noticed that my guitar says this
machine poems news on it that's because
it's the title of my new album and here
is the cover of my new album again I'm
ripping someone off not only am i
ripping off Woody Guthrie whose guitar
said this Machine Kills Fascists was
I've taken to a different though not
greater level I also was ripping off
somebody in the comments of YouTube when
I called my guitar a poner
someone in the YouTube comments said
that machine phones noobs so thank you
to that person whoever you work for
named in my album we are hoping for the
super soon release date of November 16th
that's very soon in my time anyways like
a month away and there aren't seven team
songs on the album and no none of them
are duplicate songs none of them are
talking tracks they are all songs I
can't believe I had that any songs can I
have the tracklist altogether I'll
probably be posting that on Twitter if
you follow me Twitter comm slash Hank
green also you can track me on
dailybooth dailybooth comm slash Hank
green